isn't everything silent in space as
alien told us years ago in space no one
can hear you scream how can we talk
about the sound of the big bang if
there's nothing there for the big bang
to make a sound in
[Music]
in the very early days of the universe
what you have is instead of having a
uniform just a perfectly uniform
distribution quantum mechanics tells us
we can't have that perfect uniform
distribution therefore your fluctuations
and those tiny tiny fluctuations it's
like a lumpiness of the soup but to even
be sound what you need are pressure
variations and those how are those
pressure variations set up right at the
start what you have is this soup this
plasma electrons quarks we haven't even
got atoms about four hundred thousand
three hundred and eighty thousand years
after the big bang what happens is that
everything cools down sufficiently
so that atoms can start forming before
that the issue is actually you can't see
through the universe because you've got
this dense fog this plasma tiny tiny
quantum fluctuations right at the start
get blown up very very rapidly and those
tiny fluctuations what they do is they
imprint pressure variations across the
early universe and when we look and see
the cosmic microwave background it's
telling us about those pressure
fluctuations and pressure fluctuations
tell us about sound so you could say
that actually everything that there is
the entire universe the matter around us
arises due to sound it rises due to
pressure fluctuations and what happens
in the big bang at least in the early
stages is at that moment that instant is
you don't have those pressure variations
everything's moving out radially at the
same rate actually it was silent
which seems really why would we call it
the big bang if it's silent why would it
be silent well the important thing is to
really have sound well what is sound
sound is a variation in pressure those
fluctuations those pressure variations
kicked in
rather later on right a little bit
further down the line from the big bang
so the big bang itself it's probably
best not to call it the big bang it's
probably best to call it something like
a big light rather than a big
bang the density of the universe in
terms of the matter in the universe was
a million times greater a million times
greater than it is now so the best way
to think about the universe at that
point in time is that it's all
atmosphere
it's all just it's it's all air
effectively it's all atmosphere we know
today that sound can't travel through
space why can't sound travel through
space simply because the density of the
atoms isn't high enough to allow those
sound waves to propagate but right at
those early stages the density was
beyond high enough for um sound waves to
travel across the universe so it's much
the same as you have standing waves and
then you have harmonics on a guitar
string that's the way you've got to
think about it
in terms of certain patches of space
will have a higher density certain other
patches of space will have a lower
density so it's clumped together here
and then
falls away and then you have regions
where there's a lower density and then
you can think of having one harmonic
having higher harmonics in terms of how
that matter is distributed i don't see
how this has anything to do with sound
but what is sound so again if we think
about a guitar string when you pluck
that guitar string you get a standing
wave set up on that what's happening is
that you're getting that string is
moving back and forth it's moving air
molecules back and forth and they're
hitting your your ears what's happening
there it's a pressure hang on there you
go you've started something propagating
it's not the guitar string that is sound
it's the propagation of the air being
pushed by the guitar string it is yes
but if what we can do is we can
interpret that
that pattern that we see we can
interpret those harmonics in terms of
well what is what is happening is that
the density is being pushed around the
the density the the the matter is being
pushed around and you're getting
variations in density you're getting
variations in density that means you're
getting variations in pressure that is
sound that is sound so there is stuff
moving there is there is stuff moving
yes yeah yeah but but again the best way
so why do we call it a standing wave on
a guitar string because it's it's a wave
that although the string is moving up
and down where is the maximum it's
always located at the right point if we
talk about the first harmonic it's right
at the center of the string the human
ear one here like what kind of listening
device
the the problem is
is that we're talking about frequency so
if we pluck a guitar string
i don't know we're talking about
frequencies of tens of hertz to hundreds
of hertz we're talking about periods of
a few seconds few tenths of seconds you
know hundredths of a second
when it comes to the big bang we're
talking about 10 to the minus 12 hertz
or 10 to the minus 13 hertz or a better
way of thinking about that is 50 octaves
lower than when you pluck a guitar
string so you know we listen to a guitar
string you know that's oscillating back
and forth pretty rapidly if it were the
big bang and when you're thinking about
the oscillations for the big bang then
that string is moving up and down it's
taking 20 000 to 200 000 years to do one
oscillation that's what we're talking
about so that's not just
heavy
that's not just subsonic that's sub stop
song sonic that's that's completely
outside the realm of any type of human
perception phil i always think of the
big bang as a time of incredible
energy and velocity and violence and yet
you're talking to me about things that
are moving at these sub-glacial speeds
absolutely it's it's bizarre and it's
the language we just another example of
where we use language and physics and we
borrow everyday terms which don't quite
capture does it have a note is it like a
b flat
oh that's so you can in principle work
out what that note is but the problem is
the the when you look at the spectrum
instead of having very nice peaks
frequency peaks as you have with a
guitar string where you can say you know
it's b flat or whatever the problem is
with the with the big bang when you look
at the spectrum of the big bang actually
those peaks are very broad
which means that the note
isn't isn't a well-defined
musical note it's much more much broader
and much
less distinct much more interesting
actually i'm borrowing an awful lot of
this from a guy called mark whittle at
the university of virginia he's got a
wonderful wonderful website where he
describes the what he calls big bang
acoustics others have looked at this as
well and if you go to his website then
you can actually find um wav files um
sounds
where he's taken this
spectrum transposed it to um up to 50
octaves to where we could where it's
within the range of human hearing and
you can listen to
wide range of different
aspects of the sounds of the big bang
would dogs hear the big boy
dogs wouldn't hear the big bang not
unless they lived to be 200 000 years
old
[Music]
when you look at the cosmic microwave
background let's tell you about
temperature variations but those
temperature variations as you said also
tell you about density variations those
density variations in turn will tell you
about pressure variations and once
you've got pressure variations then you
can work out how many decibels the big
bang was what we have is something
called a bell what a bell is is a
measure of the
relative loudness let's put it that way
i'm being a bit loose with words
relative loudness of two signals and the
way that's defined the bell is log to
the base 10. so it's a logarithmic
measure and the reason we do that is
because our ears work logarithmically
and what you have is let's say two
signals p2
and p1 and this is the power signal two
and this is the power signal one what we
need is a reference and let's use
slightly unusual subscripts here so
let's have a loud signal which we're
going to donate with that subscript and
let's have a quiet signal and we're
going to donate that with that subscript
now this quiet signal is a reference
signal that's taken to
generally to be the limit of human
hearing now we can quibble about what
that is and there's a lot of quibbling
about this but that's defined in terms
of a certain pressure which represents
the limit of human hearing that's a bell
however what you find is it's better to
work in decibels just in terms of the
magnitude of the numbers involved so
decibel we define slightly differently
like this but it's exactly the same idea
that's in terms of the power of the
signal this is a subtle point and a
technical point but i'm going to put it
in there because otherwise i know the
whole common section will erupt so what
we'll do now is going to convert this
from a power to a pressure and those are
related one is the square of the other
so that gives us a factor of two when it
comes to the logs and what we end up for
our final formula is something that
looks like this
db is 20 log where this is our loud
signal
and this is our quiet signal
if i can fit it all on the page so
normally in air what we do is we'd look
at the limit of human hearing in air and
think about what the pressure is
associated with that and then we think
about what the pressure is associated
with how i'm speaking here ratio the two
get the log multiply by 20 that gives
you decibels to give you an idea or what
sort of high-end decibels might be if
you're standing about i don't know 20 or
30 meters from a jet engine recover the
sound coming from the engine i can
convert that to a pressure scale then if
i take that pressure reading from the um
the jet engine compare it to the
pressure associated with the absolute
limit of human hearing get that as a
logarithm to the base 10 multiplied by
20 that gives me about 140 decibels
that's 140 decibels is as i say quite
noisy and getting to the limit of human
hearing turns out that the loudest rock
band loudest heavy metal band on the
planet it's a band called manowar which
some of you might be familiar with if
you're not familiar with man of war go
look them up hours of endless fun you
know brady i can see you're not in your
head you know i had to get a heavy metal
reference in somewhere they lay a claim
at 139 db to be the loudest band on the
planet they couldn't quite beat agent
they couldn't quite beat a jet engine
but that's pretty good but actually if
you stand just a little bit back from
the jet engine it falls off as the
inverse square
so
depending on where you are with the jet
engine man of war could be louder
so mana 139 db let's round that up
that's all good physicists didn't call
that 140 db but about the same uh level
in terms of db as a jet engine now you
might think well this is the big bang
the big bank's just going to be billions
of db
actually you look at those pressure
fluctuations you do exactly what we're
doing here of course your reference
level can't be within the
soup right at the start of the universe
it can't be the limit of human hearing
but what you can do is you can get the
average pressure
from the from the pattern from the
cosmic microwave background and then
look at the fluctuations about that if
you look at the fluctuations in pressure
well actually all you want to do is give
a reference level and then you're
looking at the variation about that
reference level that's what you're doing
when you think about the jet engine so
obviously we can't send a human back and
also it's you know happening on uh
ridiculously long time scales so we need
something artificial so we could set up
a robot we'd have to get the time
machine sorted out though brady that's
the first thing and i've been working on
that for quite some time now and it
doesn't seem to be going any anywhere
fast but let's say we got the time
machine worked out so we can send this
robot back 13.8 billion years or so and
then what we need to do is we'd have to
set it up with an artificial air and our
artificial air would have to be tolerant
of fairly extreme environments but we
could set it up so its reference level
would be
whatever the the baseline pressure is
and then we'd look at would treat it
would know of the would be programmed to
look at fluctuations about that baseline
level not look here
thank you here we know the fluctuations
we know the level of the fluctuations
remember all we want is a ratio so if we
know those fluctuations are at the level
of ten to the minus five ten to the
minus six ten to the minus seven you
know one part in a million one point ten
million one point 100 million whatever
that's that's all we need to get uh a db
value with a big bang well it's it's the
origin of everything wouldn't that just
absolutely blow your head off wouldn't
the volume just be could you exist
you know would it not just those sound
waves just completely roughed you
turns out it's not as loud as we think
it is so the number when we work this
through we look at the decibels and we
look at this these variations in
pressure turns out about 120 decibels
that's all
so not only is a jet engine louder than
the big bang
man of war is much much much louder than
the than the big bang our robot would
come out and say
wouldn't that laugh indeed that wasn't
as bad as that man of war exactly
hi everyone if you enjoyed that video
then you're definitely going to enjoy
this it's a new book by phil moriarty
who you've just been watching it's
called when the uncertainty principle
goes to 11
or
how to explain quantum physics with
heavy metal in fact the video you just
watched is partly based on a very small
section of this book i've been reading
it it's really good fun it's written
like phil speaks it's enthusiastic it's
funny i've really been enjoying it i
especially enjoy all the footnotes phil
puts lots of jokes and
unnecessary detail in the footnotes it's
almost as fun as the book itself and
another reason you should check this out
is the illustrations all the artwork in
it were done by pete mcpartlin who
animates loads of the videos on 60
symbols and number file including the
one you just watched i'm really really
happy for phil and pete they've made a
really great thing and if you want to
show them just a little bit of thanks
for all the time they've given us in
these videos over the years consider
this one when the uncertainty principle
goes to 11 i'll put links down in the
description or you can just pick it up
at your bookstore just look for that
it's coming out really really soon you
can't miss that cover can you this is
what it looks like when phil holds it
smile
he's almost as bad as me isn't he